college students often have concerns
about their financial futures many
graduate with student loan debt that
will take years to pay off but for some
students daily life is already a
struggle and that includes issues we
don't often associate with college
Carter Evans reports from Los Angeles I
truly believe that I'm going to a
different school than my peers are they
have houses right up the hill they have
everything they need that's not the UCLA
I go to while 23 year old Alejandro
Reyes may blend in perfectly on campus
he's keeping a secret for most of his
classmates he's homeless his school
locker is his closet he brushes his
teeth in a public restroom and at times
he sleeps on this sofa inside a 24-hour
campus library my first quarter here
actually lived inside of my car that's
where I had all my clothes everything I
needed for the day but after the car was
totaled in an accident a homeless
shelter a few miles away from campus was
his only option according to the US
Department of Education there were at
least 32,000 homeless college students
in 2017 Alejandro is hoping to attend
medical school so I want to be an
orthopedic surgeon Alejandro is yearly
tuition at UCLA is about $13,000 which
is covered by financial aid student
loans and a job on campus but after
books and food there's nothing left for
rent when you look at this campus the
beauty and and the prestige of being
here it's hard to imagine that some of
the students here don't have a home to
go home to it's hard to imagine
obviously it does exist it's just
difficult to grasp and put into a
quantitative form and it's not just a
housing problem a survey of students at
10 University of California campuses
reveals 48% of underclassmen are food
insecure and have to skip meals to
combat the problem UCLA even has an
on-campus food pantry where students can
pick up items for free no questions
asked the problem with homelessness and
universities is that because we don't
want to stand out that
the university has no idea that we even
exist and Alejandro will now have to
find another place to live
his shelter limit stays and his time has
already run out but he won't graduate
until 2024 CBS this morning Saturday
Carter Evans Los Angeles choice
shouldn't be whether you have shelter or
the education that you want our food on
your plate it really shouldn't be like
that I'm glad Carter's doing this story
we talk a lot about the problems that
are facing this country I never thought
about this